Kim Kardashian reveals what motherhood  has taught her I'm very happy with two  children already and a plan to have a  third via surrogate I love that the 36  year old reality star took to her app on  Friday to reflect on the lessons she's  learned since becoming a parent quote I  have such unconditional love for my kids  there can be ups and downs with kids but  no matter what I always learn so much  from them being a mom is the most  important job I have and the self  proclaimed selfie queen says Parenthood  has made her turn the lens outward more  often I love that quote my priorities  changed when I had kids it's not about  me anymore  they give me a whole new perspective and  inspire me to be the best version of  myself